بالطبع هذه مجموعة
واسعة جدًا من الأنشطة التي
تعزز برنامج مكافحة الفيروسات لدينا ، وقدرتنا على
العمل بشكل أقرب مع
الجيش الأمريكي للتدخل على سبيل المثال أه
تتدفق الأسلحة إلى اليمن وهل هذا يعني
الآن أنك لست بحاجة إلى شراء
أنظمة دفاع صاروخي من الصين
سنشتري أنظمة دفاع صاروخي
أو أي أسلحة دفاعية
حيث يمكننا إيجاد أفضل
الحلول لاحتياجاتنا ونرى
حقًا الولايات المتحدة كشريك أساسي أه
في المشتريات الدفاعية ولكن بالطبع إذا
لم نتمكن من الحصول على معدات أه الولايات المتحدة ،
فسنبحث  في أماكن أخرى ، كان الرئيس أوباما
جزءًا واضحًا جدًا من هذا السلام الجديد
مع المنطقة هو أن الصين
وروسيا أعداء ،
ولا أعتقد أنني لم
أجعل الرئيس بايدن يصف الصين بأنها عدو
، وسوف أحذر من ذلك الولايات المتحدة.
أعتقد أنه سيكون دائمًا
أهم شريك لنا في الأمن القومي ،
لكن من الحقائق أيضًا كما قلت أن
الصين هي ثاني أكبر
اقتصاد في العالم ، وأننا من أجل
أن تعيش المنطقة في العالم  الطريق
إلى الازدهار المستدام بحاجة إلى
التعاون وليس المواجهة ، اسمح
لي أن ألتقط 5g 6g
التزامك بالاستثمار في الولايات المتحدة التي
تنتج منتجات 5g 6g هل هذا
يعني أنك ستشتري القليل من
الإصدارات الصينية من هذه المنتجات نحن
نبحث دائمًا عن الأفضل بالنسبة لنا ، فما الذي
يناسب احتياجاتنا التكنولوجية ، لكننا
لن
نجعل أنفسنا حصريًا لمورد واحد
أو آخر ليس
له معنى تجاري
[موسيقى]